the Seas have never been this high
planet has never been this warm
distinguished delegates for two weeks
representatives from nearly 200
countries will hold talks in Egypt on a
continent already ravaged by severe
drought and food shortages
the annual U.N Summit is focused on
global climate action and how to pay for
it every cop is a makeup break comp
every cop counts and every cop should
move us one step closer or multiple
steps closer to that Target of halving
emissions by 2030. natural disasters are
expensive costing billions of dollars
developing countries are some of the
hardest hit by climate change and they
rely on assistance during heat waves
droughts and devastating floods like
what we saw in Pakistan earlier this
year developing countries are to
continue to invest in the climate action
that they need to take in the long term
and the short term they need to see
those funds flow from the developed
countries who have greater historical
responsibility for the causes of climate
change some say these Summits are not
helpful and take too long to reach
decisions that impact billions of people
and are only decided by the world's
Elite what do we want
when do we want it on Friday hundreds of
climate activists blocked the departure
of private jets at Amsterdam's shiple
airport to protest against the pollution
caused by the aviation industry however
some progress has been made the good
news is that the 15 countries have been
able to reduce their emissions during
the past 15 years it's mostly European
countries Japan United States Singapore
and we have also much better
technological means to be successful in
climate mitigation the prices of solar
and wind energy have been dropping hello
expectations are high for this climate
Summit but after a year of unprecedented
natural disasters action may come too
late for some
Leah Harding Al Jazeera